et le débat de ce club consacré aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 le top départ sera donné dans un
peu plus d'un an et d'autres territoires
que Paris sont concernés évidemment on
va en parler alors serons-nous prêts et
à quel coup la sécurité des athlètes et
des spectateurs seraient-elle garantie
ces jeux seront-ils accessibles au plus
grand nombre c'est à toutes ces
questions que nous allons tenter de
répondre ce matin Michel Savin bonjour
merci d'être avec nous bonjour
événements Jacques Pâquier bonjour merci
d'être là directeur de la rédaction du
journal du Grand Paris on vous a souvent
distances on est ravi de vous avoir sur
ce plateau et en visio à distance pour
le coup Stéphane Troussel bonjour
Stéphane Troussel merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes le président
socialiste du conseil départemental de
la Seine-Saint-Denis c'est chez vous
qu'on va aller pour débuter ce club
Stéphane Roussel puisque pour préparer
ces Jeux Olympiques des dizaines de
chantiers sont en cours à Paris et en
Île-de-France Gaspard flamand et
Juliette Richard nous emmène dans les
coulisses du chantier le plus imposant
celui du centre aquatique à Saint-Denis
avec une question qu'à l'avenir pour
toutes ces infrastructures après les
jeux on regarde
à quelques pas du plus Grand Stade
Français le plus gros chantier des Jeux
olympiques de Paris c'est aussi le plus
cher 170 millions d'euros pour
construire le centre aquatique des jeux
qui accueillera les épreuves de natation
au centre une piscine de 50 mètres avec
à côté un bassin de plongeon à la forme
innovante on se retrouve actuellement
sur la plateforme du plongeon à 10 m sur
le plus haut plongeoir du centre
aquatique est-ce que vous pouvez voir
par ailleurs donc c'est la forme inégale
du du fond de bassin
notamment l'endroit où vous êtes en
train de filmer sur le sur le fond du
bassin de plongeon qui a une forme un
petit peu d'entonnoir pour optimiser
économiser les volumes d'eau résultat
une économie d'eau de 10% sur la
totalité du bassin le toit est lui aussi
pensé pour faire des économies avec
cette charpente en bois courbée la
surface intérieure est réduite ce qui
réduit donc aussi la quantité d'air à
chauffer en sortant du bâtiment les
spectateurs auront accès à une
passerelle qui le relie au Stade de
France
on se retrouve actuellement sur le
franchissement au-dessus de l'autoroute
A1 qui vient d'être inaugurée et qui a
été réalisé par la métropole du Grand
Paris se franchissement et la vocation à
relier les équipements sportifs pendant
la phase olympique avec évidemment le
Stade de France mais aussi le centre
aquatique olympique qui est juste là à
deux pas pendant les Jeux c'est de
passerelle facilitera les déplacements
entre ces deux infrastructures mais elle
a aussi été pensée pour les années à
venir la ville de Saint-Denis est
particulièrement marquée par des
infrastructures
urbaines qui malheureusement créé
quelques fractures territoriales demain
les habitants du quartier du Stade de
France et ceux du quartier de la Plaine
Sauvenier qui se réalisera au lendemain
des Jeux Olympiques pourront tout
simplement se rejoindre à travers une
passerelle qui permettra de raccourcir
grandement les temps de parcours entre
ces deux quartiers
pour le début de la compétition dans un
an 64 chantiers sont en cours de
nouvelles infrastructures comme ce
centre aquatique mais aussi des
rénovations et des aménagements la
plupart se trouvent en Seine-Saint-Denis
le département qui bénéficiera le plus
de l'héritage matériel des jeux une
volonté depuis le début de
l'organisation
c'est le territoire à la fois le plus
jeune mais aussi le plus pauvre de
France et il y avait un besoin de
transformation territoriale important
mais ce qu'on voulait répondre c'est les
besoins qui étaient ceux des habitants
pour les périodes seront après les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques c'était ça
notre postulat de reconstruire peu et
construire utile en 2025 quelques mois
après la fin des jeux le grand public
aura accès au centre aquatique
chez vous
pour le début de ces Jeux Olympiques on
voit il y a beaucoup de chantiers en
cours notamment dans votre département
oui il y a il y a pas d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui les chantiers sont bien en
cours dans les temps et y compris après
la période difficile que nous avons
connu avec les périodes de confinement
liées à la crise sanitaire et bien des
mesures ont été prises pour vraiment
rattraper ces moments difficiles et on
peut dire aujourd'hui que les délais
seront tenus et les équipements livrés
et les clés transmises à Paris 2024
comme prévu c'est un message optimiste
ça fait du bien pour commencer ce club
la semaine dernière Michel Savin le CIO
une délégation en tout cas était en
visite à Paris nous repartons Paris avec
un grand niveau de confiance ont-ils dit
tout va bien oui je pense que c'est
confirmé au niveau des équipements tout
d'abord le calendrier je pense on va
être tenu et c'est c'est un message
important et qui a été envoyé au monde
des CIO il fallait rassurer tout le
monde pour faire voir que la France est
incapacité d'organiser correctement ces
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
besoin aujourd'hui sur cette partie du
territoire peut-être un regret quand
même c'est que Paris la région
parisienne n'auront pas non plus une
deuxième halle de sport on voit que le
basket doit s'expatrier à Lille pour
pour cette compétition parce que et dans
l'avenir et on peut regretté que que
c'est la région parisienne et Paris
n'est pas à l'équipement pour accueillir
des grandes compétitions internationales
sur le basket Lamballe et le volley-ball
donc on ne respirait mais bon après il y
a aussi les coudes de construction le
budget à tenir mais voilà c'est
peut-être un petit regret surtout en
termes d'héritage d'équipement
on a voulu collectivement effectivement
que la candidature de Paris pour 2024
soit une candidature économe qui
s'appuie sur un certain nombre
d'équipements existants qu'il a fallu
parfois rénover étendre et adapté aux
besoins des compétitions vous savez moi
si j'ai engagé la Seine-Saint-Denis dans
ce dans ce projet le département va
mobiliser
plus de 80 millions d'euros c'est pour
accélérer un certain nombre de
transformation et notamment en étant
tourné bien sûr sur la réussite des 30
jours de compétition mais surtout sur
les 30 années d'héritage pour
transformer nos villes pour
relier des quartiers pour faire des
ponts sur les autoroutes la Seine parce
que effectivement ça a été dit dans
votre reportage la Seine-Saint-Denis a
été marquée par un certain nombre de
d'infrastructures qui ont souvent coupé
nos territoires couper les quartiers
couper les villes donc cette question là
elle est très importante il y a il y a
l'exemple de la passerelle qui va au
dessus de l'autoroute qui va relier le
centre aquatique olympique et le stade
le Stade de France mais il y a aussi
plusieurs passerelles sur sur la Seine
un autre pont sur l'autoroute A1 du côté
du Bourget des des équipements sportifs
je l'ai dit à grandi au rénover des
logements il faut rappeler que
l'andancer deux quartiers le village des
athlètes et le village des médias d'unis
Le Bourget ça s'est appuyé d'abord sur
des visions des quartiers imaginés par
les élus locaux que justement les jeux
sont venus accélérer et permet va
permettre de les réaliser dans un temps
record à un moment où notamment la
région parisienne a un besoin criant de
logement donc oui on tient cette cet
objectif là encore une fois d'accélérer
les transformations et de faire en sorte
qu'on ait une candidature ou Hollande au
lendemain quand la flamme sera atteinte
on pourra se dire collectivement qu'il
n'y a pas d'éléphant blanc qui reste
comme ça et qui seraient utilisé c'est
souvent une des critiques qui a été
formulée à l'occasion d'édition des jeux
précédents on va parler de ce sujet du
logement vous parliez Stéphane Troussel
du fait que la candidature de Paris
voulait une candidature économe et on va
parler justement du coup de cjoji
puisque la cour des qui suivent
évidemment de près cette question il y a
un rapport qui a fuité dans le monde qui
doit être remis au Parlement dans
quelques jours vous nous le direz qu'il
est sans tente de fortes incertitudes
qui persistent sur l'équilibre des
comptes est-ce qu'il y a un risque de
dérive financière non il y a pas de je
pense que vraiment c'est une façon de
d'aborder le problème qui est un petit
peu tronqué il est le budget passé de
6,9 milliards d'euros à 8,8 milliards
d'euros pour des raisons qu'on connaît
sont liées à l'inflation bon ça bien
bien malin celui qui pourrait s'en
extraire et puis par le des problèmes
liés aux difficultés d'approvisionnement
donc je sais pas faudrait faire
l'addition si la soustraction ça a cru
de 1 milliard d'euros c'est un événement
à 9 milliards d'euros 4 milliards
d'euros faut un peu rappeler les
fondamentaux 4 milliards d'euros pour
les ouvrages parce qu'il y a les
logements vous en parliez il y a les
équipements 4 milliards d'euros pour la
compétition avec 3 milliards d'euros
d'argent public mais ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que c'est 32 Coupe du Monde c'est
ce que je voulais dire quand même aussi
un peu en introduction c'est
l'équivalent de 32 Coupes du Monde c'est
50 compétitions par jour
c'est l'équivalent du réseau de bus de
Lyon du Grand Lyon qui va être ajouté je
suis un peu hors sujet mais je veux dire
que c'est un événement absolument majeur
considérable c'est toute la c'est toute
la terre qui va nous regarder et et bien
sûr ça va apporter aussi ça va rapporter
ça c'est si chiffré c'est entre 1,5 et
3,5 milliards d'euros
les risques si je voulais ils sont bons
bois ça va peut-être coûter un peu plus
j'espère qu'il y aura pas de dérapage je
ne connais pas le rapport auquel vous
faites allusion peut-être que monsieur
le sénateur va en parler mais ce qu'il
faut je pense parce que Monsieur trucel
parlait d'héritage à ce stade c'est
c'est faire de cet événement vraiment
quelque chose de fédérateur moi je pense
que si un problème de coup c'est plutôt
celui des places parce que je sais pas
beaucoup de place à 700 euros je suis
désolé c'est pas comme ça alors qu'au
départ c'était 24 euros je sais pas si
vous suivez ce dossier j'ai pas bien
compris parce que ça c'est un peu gênant
parce que vrai c'est un sujet qui mérite
l'adhésion populaire mais juste sur le
coup est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
attendez est-ce que vous savez plus
précisément ce qu'il y a dans ce rapport
vous Michel Savin est-ce que pour vous
il y a un risque de dérapage financ oui
une augmentation de la dépense qui était
prévue alors est-ce que c'est ces jeux
étaient sous-estimés aussi est-ce qu'on
peut se poser la question lorsqu'on
compare avec les précédents jeux Tokyo
c'était 12 milliards Londres c'était au
14 milliards d'euros donc on voit bien
qu'on est dans des proportions bien
inférieures pour Paris alors est-ce que
l'estimation assimiler avec elle qui
était peut-être un peu sous-estimée
est-ce qu'il y a des frais alors bien
sûr il y a tout ce qu'il y a à la crise
covid mais aussi Ukraine et l'inflation
qui fait gonfler l'enveloppe des
dépenses et puis je pense qu'il y a des
décisions qui ont été prises qui qui ont
une répercussion aussi sur l'aspect
financier le fait de faire ça va être
quelque chose d'extraordinaire en terme
de de d'image qui va être envoyée dans
le monde entier la cérémonie d'ouverture
sur la scène c'est quelque chose qui va
être extraordinaire qui va mettre en
avant toute la beauté de Paris mais ça a
un coup c'est pas disproportionné
qui vient gonfler l'addition de des JO
qui était peut-être pas prévu au départ
et en termes de sécurité d'aménagement
de d'aménagement et puis et bien sûr il
y a des dérapages peut-être aussi c'est
pointé dans le rapport comme quoi en
terme de de personnel et de de
recrutement il y a peut-être eu des
choses un petit peu disproportionnées
Stéphane Troussel pardon allez-y oui il
faut il faut redire quand même que dans
le budget des jeux c'est deux deux
entités c'est à la fois
le budget de la solideo qui construit
les équipements les infrastructures avec
un toute une série de mètres d'ouvrages
ville de Paris département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis métropole etc pleine
commune
l'île de Marseille et bien d'autres
c'est donc la seule vidéo à peu près la
moitié du budget et le Kojo qui est
l'organisateur des compétitions des
cérémonies de de la communication etc du
marketing et de l'ensemble des de ce qui
va permettre l'organisation de de
l'événement
s'agissant de la et c'est à peu près
donc la moitié sur cette moitié il n'y a
pas d'argent public il n'y a pas
d'argent public c'est uniquement de
l'argent privé de la billetterie les sur
la c'est la seule vidéo qui est composée
de l'argent public avec un fort
investissement de l'État et des
collectivités locales et s'agissant de
ce budget là et bien il est tenu alors
bien sûr oui il y a eu l'inflation les
difficultés d'approvisionnement la
nécessité y compris d'accélérer un
certain nombre de chantiers quand ils
pouvaient y avoir des difficultés mais
ce budget là il est tenu et y compris
l'ensemble des observateurs le disent il
n'y a pas de dérapage dans les dans ces
projets et encore une fois et bien quand
on accélère la construction de logements
réalise de la voirie des grandes
infrastructures et bien quand on peut
réagir Michel ça va et Jacques paquet
est-ce que vous dites Stéphane Roussel
parce que ils ont pas l'air complètement
d'accord non je suis pas totalement
d'accord alors c'est vrai que concernant
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
elle-même l'équipement assez vrai que
les recettes sont liées bien sûr et la
part du CIO qui vient apporter une
participation importante il y a des
droits TV il y a les publier partenaires
et puis il y a les billetterie mais si
tout ça n'arrive pas à équilibrer le
budget c'est bien de l'argent public
c'est l'État qui est qui est qui a
engagé budgétairement 3 milliards
d'euros pour venir couvrir les les
dépenses qui seraient pas couvertes par
des recettes donc c'est bien de l'argent
public quand vous dites qu'il y a pas
d'argent de X si l'État s'est engagé à
mettre 3 milliards sur la sur la table
pour couvrir tout dérapages financiers
c'est de l'argent public ce que je veux
dire non mais moi je parle de
l'organisation
aujourd'hui
il y a des rapports qui ont montré que
historiquement il y a toujours une
sous-estimation des dépenses une
surestimation des recettes ça c'est
systématique on y coupera pas mais c'est
comme le disait très bien Stéphane
Roussel et je suis entièrement d'accord
avec lui il faut regarder ce que ça
finance et l'effort tous les Ford de
l'ensemble des élus etc consiste à
éviter que ces dépenses qui sont
importantes ne se concentrent que sur
les trois semaines des jeux ce qui
serait effectivement un peu inconscient
dans la période qu'on vit mais j'ai
plein d'exemples et il y a des exemples
d'innovation par exemple sur le village
des athlètes les stations de les bornes
de recharge électrique pour véhicules
électriques serviront non seulement à
charger les véhicules mais aussi à
stocker enfin permettront à ce que les
véhicules puissent se stocker de
l'énergie ça c'est du niveau une
innovation tout à fait intéressante il y
a cinq piscines notamment chez vous
Stéphane vous le dites à chaque occasion
c'est une transformation pour la
Seine-Saint-Denis je veux dire que il
faut bien sûr et c'est le rôle des
parlementaires de la Cour des comptes de
veiller à ce que l'argent public soit
bien dépensé et il l'est parce que tout
ça est orchestré par des gens de très
haut niveau j'ai des Nicolas Ferrand qui
dirige la solideo est un aménageurs de
premier ordre et je pense qu'il faut en
faire une occasion non pas de façon béni
oui ou stupide parce que il y a des
points de vigilance du territoire d'une
part et puis une opération de fiert une
occasion de fierté parce que le
savoir-faire des entreprises qu'on va
pas citer mais des aménageurs des élus
qui sont totalement mobilisés et c'est
voilà je dis pas par intérêt vraiment et
remarquable il faut qu'il faut susciter
l'adhésion sur un un événement
extraordinaire
moi je suis d'accord sur tout ce que ce
qui est dit par rapport à l'héritage par
rapport aux enjeux et on est tous 5 le
sel mais le seul mais il y a plein de
choses tout ça la question qui est posée
est-ce que c'est financièrement c'est
équilibré ou pas les recettes au niveau
de de l'organisation des Jeux elle est
basée sur la participation de duo sur
les droits TV sur les partenaires et sur
la billetterie si la totalité de ces
recettes ne couvre pas la totalité des
dépenses sera bien un déficit qui doit
être supporté en partie par l'État c'est
simplement ce que je dis mais c'est
l'engagement qui a pris l'État et qui
devrait être respecté
la même chose qu'on parle des jeux on va
jouer on va jouer avec vous Audrey
puisque vous nous avez préparé un petit
quiz sur ces JO 2024 oui j'ai organisé
mes propres jeux
mais bon allez on va tenter de on va
tenter de s'amuser c'est un vrai ou faux
donc vous me dites vrai ou faux monsieur
Roussel on va vous faire participer vrai
ou faux les jeux de paris seront les
plus écolos vrai oui vrai et ben vous
avez raison c'est vrai même s'il faut le
concéder les organisateurs ont revu
leurs ambitions à la baisse ils
voulaient que les jeux apportent une
contribution positive pour le climat on
se contentera et c'est déjà pas mal de
diviser par deux les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre par rapport à Londres en
2012 Rio en 2016 qui avait généré 3,5
millions de tonnes de carbone c'est donc
déjà pas mal concrètement on fait
comment bah comme vous l'avez dit on
utilise 90% de sites déjà existants
l'électricité sera renouvelable pas de
clim dans le village olympique faudra
faire avec recours à la seconde main et
pas de vaisselle à usage unique
n'oublions pas non plus que les athlètes
devraient évoluer dans la scène
dépolluer les jeux de paris devraient
même servir d'exemples pour de futurs
compétitions donc deuxième question
deuxième question vrai ou faux les jeux
de paris seront les plus inclusifs
vrai bref je pense Stéphane Roussel
on aurait pu faire beaucoup mieux
l'organisation les organisateurs pardon
le concept en tout cas pour l'instant un
exemple actuellement seul 6% des
stations de métro sont accessibles aux
personnes à mobilité réduite contre 31%
à Londres 27 % à New York et même 100% à
Barcelone alors on met les bouchées
doubles pour accueillir les trois pardon
350 le matin décidément mais j'arrive
pas 350 000 visiteurs en situation de
handicap ont réhausse les quais on met
des balises sonores on revoit les bandes
de guidage on met des points
d'assistance mais il y a encore beaucoup
de travail un peu plus d'un an des Jeux
je pensais que vous parliez
le département en l'occurrence a pris la
décision de construire un équipement qui
s'appelle prisme à Bobigny qui est à un
équipement sportif dans la conception a
été imaginé telle origine à vocation
universelle et qui est une qui va servir
de site d'entraînement parce que ça sera
un bel héritage du point de vue de la
démonstration que nous pouvons faire sur
la pratique partagée du sport
sans doute et tous et à vocation
universelle et inclusive
les entreprises non non mais je crois
que les entreprises sont en avance sur
ce qui est du quota vous savez des
heures d'insertion et ça c'est donc ça
c'est ça fait partie du caractère
inclusif j'insiste sur les places on en
parlera peut-être que ça le couple
pas une troisième question les jeux
seront 100% accessibles sans voiture oui
vrai je sais pas
ils le seront par le dispositif de
transport existants mais
le grand regret c'est que les lignes du
Grand Paris Express hormis la ligne 14
ne seront pas prêtes pour la livraison
des jeux en tout cas c'est le défi un
point important en vélo ça pourrait être
incroyable 400 km de voie cyclables sont
en cours de travaux pour relier tous les
sites olympiques c'est l'originalité de
ces jeux et apparemment ça avance bien
côté transport vous l'avez dit ça patine
un peu dans l'Ouest parisien pour aller
au Parc des Princes notamment la seule
ligne de métro 9 ne suffira pas donc il
y a des concertations pour organiser des
navettes et puis concernant la ligne 14
vous l'avez dit aussi Valérie Pécresse
la présidente assure qu'elle sera prête
au printemps 2024 mais voilà on va
parler de cette question j'interromps un
peu le jeu Audrey pardon mais cette
question des transports est-ce qu'ils
sont prêts moi je pense qu'ils sont pas
prêts c'était pas on n'est pas
l'objectif qui était inscrit au moment
de la candidature on est loin de ce qui
avait été proposé simplement une petite
parenthèse les jeux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques n'est pas uniquement Paris
d'autres villes vont accueillir des
compétitions c'est pour ça que moi je
vous ai répondu non parce que si vous
allez à Lille à Marseille au dos je
pense que là il y a beaucoup de de
supporters et de spectateurs qui rend
encore utilisé leur véhicule donc c'est
pour ça que ne limitons pas uniquement
les jeux la grosse partie sera bien sûr
sur Paris la région parisienne mais
aussi d'autres villes françaises qui
vont accueillir des compétitions non moi
je dis que au lendemain de ce qui s'est
passé sur la ligne 4 je voudrais le dire
sous forme de boutade c'est que si
jamais ça ça déconnait pendant les JO ce
qu'on n'aura pas de problème c'est à
chercher les responsables tant ils sont
nombreux c'est que c'est ce cas pointé
le rapport de Stéphane Mazar et de
Stéphane peu récemment le rapport des
députés sur la les retombées économiques
c'est qu'il y a deux sujets de vigilance
les transports et la sécurité et pour
ces deux sujets il y a un problème de
coordination des acteurs parce que qu'il
s'agisse de transport ou de sécurité on
est dans un pays où il y a trop
qui se penche sur le berceau et ça c'est
aussi des inquiétudes sur la sécurité de
ces jeux
là-dessus on peut en parler c'est
notamment le sport il y a effectivement
c'est un point de vigilance absolue bien
évidemment à la fois pour que bon
notamment la ligne 14 qui va desservir
le la gare de Saint-Denis Pleyel soit
bien livré dans les temps parce que ça
sera finalement le seul la seule
infrastructure lourde supplémentaire qui
sera livrée mais il y a toutes les
autres difficultés sur lesquelles il
faut observer et agir de manière
absolument déterminée pour renouveler le
matériel pour augmenter les fréquences
l'intensité
du fonctionnement et puis moi j'ai un
sujet par exemple d'inquiétude c'est le
fait que le l'ouverture à la concurrence
des lignes de bus de la RATP dans le
Grand Paris le calendrier n'est pas été
reporté ça c'est un j'espère le ministre
Clément beau hier dans un quotidien
appelé à beaucoup de pragmatisme sur
cette question il ne faudrait pas
ajouter aux justement à ces questions
relativement difficile en matière de
transport on le voit on l'a vu encore
hier sur la ligne 4 un conflit social
d'ampleur
à la veille à la veille des Jeux je
pense que ce sera le cas de même qu'il
la ZF la montée en puissance de la zone
affaiblissement va être reportée sans
doute pour les mêmes raisons parce qu'on
va pas ajouter des conflit social à aux
difficultés un mot sur la sécurité
puisque le Parlement voté une loi
là-dessus c'était le 12 avril dernier
pour garantir la sécurité des Jeux
Olympiques il y a notamment la vidéo
surveillance algorithmique c'est un peu
la mesure phare de ce projet c'est des
algorithmes qui vont se nourrir de
caméra de drones pour détecter les
événements potentiellement dangereux
est-ce que cette loi elle garantit la
sécurité ou que les est-ce que les
inquiétudes sont encore là cette loi
permettra de surtout d'améliorer la
capacité aux forces de l'ordre et à
l'ensemble des dépôts publics de mieux à
sécuriser les sites ça résoudra pas à
100% le risque de de d'avoir un incident
et on sait qu'aujourd'hui le risque
d'attentat existe toujours on sait aussi
qu'aujourd'hui certains groupes
ultra gauche sont aussi sensibilisés
pour essayer de de voilà de perturber un
peu ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
donc c'est quelque chose qui met en plus
mais c'est vrai que c'est le c'est le
sujet numéro 1 et on voit que on est
quand même aujourd'hui avec une certaine
inquiétude en termes de mobilisation des
personnels on mobilise la gendarmerie la
police les entreprises privées qui ont
des difficultés recrutées déjà
aujourd'hui avec une problématique de
formation le ministre de l'Intérieur a
parlé de même de mobiliser l'armée donc
on voit bien que et tout ça on n'a pas
encore de chiffrage qui va prendre en
charge la totalité du coût de cette
opération de sécurité aussi bien de la
cérémonie d'ouverture que l'ensemble des
Jeux Olympiques ça c'est un qui reste
aussi en question à la sur l'aspect
financier
toutes sortes de problèmes de sécurité
il y aura cette formidable cérémonie
d'ouverture le long de la Seine je crois
que maintenant tout le monde le sait du
pont d'Austerlitz au Trocadéro une
centaine de bateaux 600000 personnes
dont 300000 gratuitement quand même faut
le dire et ça ça pose des petits
problèmes de sécurité mais j'aime bien
ce que dit Pierre Rabat dans l'adjoint
Dani dalgo au sport il faut y aller avec
non pas la fleur au fusil ni une sorte
de de d'angélisme mais c'est une fête ce
sera une fête magnifique encore une fois
avec le une fête planétaire la
transition avec la dernière question
Jacques dernière question
vous allez
bien c'est ce qu'il faut a été à tout
prix et vous avez compris mon obsession
c'est cette histoire de place il faut
vous expliquer
on va dire vrai à condition que qui qui
que quelque chose se passe sur ce sujet
je crains que c'était l'objectif qu'il
soit pas atteint Stéphane Roussel
je le crois moi je ne crois
non mais il faut être cohérent on ne
peut pas dire il faut pas mettre de
l'argent public notamment dans les
questions d'organisation et ensuite ne
pas constater par exemple que dans les
billets qui sont vendus il y en aura 50
% à moins de 50 euros alors oui dans les
50% restants il y a des billets très
chers parce qu'il y a des gens sur la
planète qui sont prêts à mettre beaucoup
d'argent pour acheter des billets très
chers mais encore une fois il y a 50%
des billets qui sont à moins de 50 euros
par contre par contre oui entre l'État
qui annonce 400 000 billets achetés par
l'État le département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis va en acheter à peu
près 40000 les autres collectivités
locales et je vais de France
les autres collectivités de
Seine-Saint-Denis la ville de Marseille
est bien d'autres la région la métropole
il faut absolument qu'il y ait une
coordination entre nous une coordination
entre nous pour faire en sorte que les
publics les plus fragiles les plus
modestes je pense je pense aux personnes
âgées je pense aux personnes en
situation de handicap le mouvement
sportif local puisse bénéficier de ces
places que la puissance publique aura
acheté
un sujet qui m'interpelle ceux et qui
m'inquiète aujourd'hui sur le coup c'est
parce que bien sûr c'est les jeux de
paris de la région parisienne mais c'est
les jeux de la France et aujourd'hui que
des personnes qui ont acheté des billets
et moi c'est le retour au jardin et qui
veulent aujourd'hui soit louer
louer une chambre d'hôtel soit louer les
amis les Airbnb aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que les prix sont en train de
flamber et j'ai même des gens
aujourd'hui qui sont prêts à revendre
leur billet parce qu'ils me disent entre
le prix du train les déplacements et le
l'accueil sur Paris qui est en train de
flamber sur cette période là aujourd'hui
il reste plus que 5 % des hôtels qui ont
des chambres libres à plus de 200 euros
la chambre donc c'est un vrai problème
donc et on aura l'occasion
il faut qu'on garde
tout quotidien régionaux avec Audrey
y
[Musique]
et Audrey une nouvelle fois c'est la
sécheresse qui fait la une de nos
quotidiens oui juste avant j'avais dit
vrai faux donc vous avez raison tous les
deux sécheresse en effet en une de nos
quotidiens d'après le Courrier de
l'Ouest la ville d'Angers a décidé
d'être proactive à l'anticipe déjà une
potentielle sécheresse cet été
l'objectif c'est de préserver dès
maintenant la ressource en eau avec des
arbitrages on apprend que seuls deux
terrains de sport seront arrosés cet été
en pleine grise qui dit sécheresse dit
aussi risque d'incendie et pas forcément
que dans le sud de la France la Côte
d'Or se prépare nous rapporte le bien
public le préfet a fait des annonces
interdictions notamment de faire du feu
en pleine nature jusqu'en octobre et
enfin les Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace
mettent en avant une solution pour
consommer moins d'eau dans l'agriculture
miser sur les légumineuses lentilles
pois chiches autres légumes secs dont
les plants ne nécessitent pas
d'irrigation et qui offre une
intéressante piste de diversification
Midi Libre un témoignage poignant suit
de l'ex athlète et moi audio oui qui
témoigne justement elle a pratiqué
l'athlétisme de haut niveau pendant 10
ans 10 ans pendant lesquelles pas eu à
faire dit-elle à des comportements de
violence d'emprise surtout de la part de
ses entraîneurs des manipulations
mentales qui ont eu raison de sa
carrière elle décrit des choses assez
difficiles j'étais au bord de la
fracture de fatigue selon les médecins
mon corps l'achète mais mon coach
continuait de pousser
on va encore pour terminer oui je vous
emmène avec du wing-foy si on a encore
un tout petit peu de temps une
discipline qui existe depuis moins de 4
ans en fait c'est un foil attaché à un
espèce de ma sous la planche ça permet
de s'envoler et le champion et Corse
justement c'est une fierté local
c'est pour l'instant non ça pourrait ça
n'existe que depuis
Michel Savin et merci Stéphane Troussel
nous on se retrouve demain pour voir
renfort cette émission c'est sur notre
nouvelle plateforme public sénat.fr à
18h vous avez rendez-vous avec Thomas u
très bonne journée à demain
[Musique]